my friends and I are working on a design
thinking project to help the elderly
people improve their lives so what kind
of problems the only people here
well my grandma's always complaining
about her body a issue I know this old
man who lives a few stories below me and
he's always talking about how he styie
even after the simplest choice
[Music]
but before that we need to identify a
user with a problem and also call our
attention right away
I am Elohim our tosya tosya tosya uncle
I suppose it's your turn come tiny so
Kamala Khan tonight's outcome
long low Hall good your card here on
your loan I'm gonna use some opium quite
um ya know bein ah what being quite down
now I'm gonna advise anima really how to
customize a solution just for angle so
the first step is to understand him
okay what do we know about uncle so what
kind of person is he and what does he
need I think also is a very shy person
he doesn't like being seen focusing well
I think he's afraid of being looked down
on by members of the public there is a
social stigma against elderly people
with walking disabilities I'm pretty
worried for him because if he doesn't
leave the working stage we might fall
down
[Music]
now we can better define what uncle so
truly needs if not the case I think
Angus own needs a walking stick that
doesn't know that all things
yeah I'm kind of a walking stick that
gives walking support but you at the
same time I think and also love there
[Music]
but what exactly is a walking stick that
doesn't look like a walking stick
all of our mistakes occur so can hide it
easily and only was he when you need
store how about we embellish talking
stick with a really beautiful headpiece
so that people wouldn't know that it's
working stick no why don't we create a
detachable umbrella support that can
transform an umbrella into a walking
stick since ever uses an umbrella
there's no stigma that's a great idea
and this umbrella walking stick and Fiat
Bravo or no no this you can use it just
as a walking support but when it rains
he can use it as an umbrella as well
yeah I think I'm going to it loved it so
much because he's so comfortable with
using umbrella yeah everyone agrees that
I here is brilliant so why wait
let's make a prototype with the idea hey
guys I just cut out this to make the
basic structure if I you worker okay how
is your rubbish it will be I'm according
to Swiss measurements I need to know how
much picture you walking me okay
[Music]
[Applause]
even though we are in love with our
invention it is more important that
uncle so loves it too isn't it
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow horse watching just sue your to
submit into pillar key Suho tr4 swallow
voice I pinch IRA oh I see bowl of horny
y-yeah I Hayley my lasso yeah
watch what adventure
[Music]
you
[Music]